here's a tricky question let Lambda be  the product of 26 binomials x minus a x  minus B and so on to x minus Z  how many terms are in the expansion of  the following product a minus Lambda  multiplied by B minus Lambda and so on  to Z minus Lambda  let's work this out logically  the binomial before x minus Z will be x  minus y and the binomial before that  will be x minus X but we know x minus X  is equal to zero substituting that into  the product we will see the entire  product will vanish so Lambda is equal  to zero  then we substitute in for Lambda and we  have a minus 0 B minus 0 and so on so  this will be a multiplied by B and so on  to Z so we have a b and so on to Z and  that will be exactly one term which is  the answer